and finally new rule don't make world
war iii all about you
watching the reactions to war in ukraine
these past few weeks it's become obvious
that america in this age suffers acutely
from a particular disease of the mind
which is everything proves what we
already believed and everything goes
back to the thing we already hate
all issues today pandemic war whatever
become a stress test for our reflexive
partisanship
can you take a vastly complex situation
that is 100 not about your thing and
somehow still make it about your thing
and our answer is watch me
americans will put anything new in our
mouths and nothing new in our heads
so naturally republicans blamed ukraine
on biden being the worst president ever
and democrats blamed it on trump's being
the worst president ever
which he was there is that
but
i'm not sure i can follow biden's logic
all the way when he dragged january 6th
into this he said look how would you
feel if you saw a crowd storm and break
down the doors of the british parliament
kill five cops injure 145 or the german
bundestag or the italian parliament i
think you'd wonder
okay but if putin thought trump was
really that supportive of him
why didn't he invade when trump was in
office
it's at least worth asking that question
if you're not locked into one
intransigent thought
now one guy we know who's locked into
one thought is donald trump who when
asked what went wrong with ukraine said
well what went wrong was a rigged
election
kanye thinks less about pete davidson
than trump thinks about the rigged
election
[Applause]
his son is obsessed with biden's son who
knows why hunter biden is a nerdwell
entitled son of privilege with a party
boy past and don jr
never mind
but
for whatever reason don jr seems
obsessed with hunter so when ukraine
happened
don tweeted will it ultimately be
hunter's lucrative and shady as [ __ ]
business dealings in ukraine that gets
us into a war with russia
uh let me feel that one for you minnie
mook no
nicole hannah jones is the curator of
the 1619 project which posits racism as
the deciding factor in pretty much every
single issue in america or apparently
everywhere she said we should care about
ukraine but not because the people
appear white all people deserve to be
free and to be welcomed when their
countries are at war
of course
agreed
and the people there don't appear white
they are
[Applause]
maybe it should be a reminder that payne
does not have a monopoly on race i know
racism is bad but other things are bad
too it's not like an avocado you don't
have to put it on everything
republican presidential hopeful nikki
haley knows why this mess happened the
reason ukraine is in the situation is
the united states has been completely
and totally distracted
we have to stop this national
self-loathing that's happening in our
country oh of course
self-loathing i hate myself for not
thinking of that
thank you
can you guess what pat robertson thinks
is behind the war in ukraine
i'll give you i'll give you a hint in
1980 1990 2006 and 2020 pat predicted
the end of the world
due to some troubling story in the news
now pat says putin went into the ukraine
but that wasn't his goal his goal was to
move against israel
because that's where the bible says the
world will end in israel it's where pat
gets raptured up to jesusville
[Applause]
by way of ukraine
who's booking this trip delta
[Applause]
and then it gets really strange
q anon john says i don't see this
invasion of ukraine as a bad thing i see
it as clearing out of a very corrupt
center of operations for the cabal ah
yes the cabal that's the pedophile ring
of elitist baby eaters
that q anon believes is the real problem
in the world and naturally when war
breaks out it's really about that
no wonder the government puts chips in
the vaccine to track you people
[Applause]
by now anyone other than a total idiot
should see a pattern but in case lauren
beaubert is watching
let me continue
uh vanity fair wants you to know that
the fight for ukraine is also a fight
for lgbtq rights and conversely colonel
mitchell swann a republican running for
congress in georgia believes allowing
transgender individuals to serve sends a
message to our adversaries that we are
more focused on social experimentation
than on the defense of our nation i see
i see yes transgender that's the key to
the ukrainian situation
yeah putin was on the fence about
invading and then one night he was
watching a mash rerun and
send in the tanks
fox news is monica crowley's previous
obsession has been cancelled culture and
now she says russia is being canceled
really really she said that she said i
mean between the fierce ukrainian
resistance and the sanctions russia is
being canceled wait the ukrainians
shouldn't resist an invasion because
that makes them part of cancel culture
but isn't their country what's getting
cancelled
you know
justin bieber once visited anne frank's
attic in amsterdam and he wrote in the
guest book and was a great girl
hopefully she would have been a belieber
that's what you people sound like
don't take this personally but don't
take everything personally
ukraine is not mostly about your pet
grievances it's about vladimir putin's
and putin is bad very very very bad but
he's still better than the guy who
brings every conversation around to
bitcoin
my pet cause
is peter the people for the ethical
treatment of animals but i don't think
ukraine got invaded because we haven't
neutered enough cats
and i guarantee you that right now
somewhere some guy who can't get it up
is telling a girl this never happened
before ukraine
you